(electronic music)
- I just wanna start
and go, and go, and go,
the longest amount of
time that I can draw,
before the tide comes in
and washes everything away.
(bright electronic music)
My name is Jim Denevan.
I draw in the sand.
To draw in the sand, it's a
balance between a mental game
and a physical.
They're both equally important.
I started drawing in the sand
a little more than 20 years ago.
I was walking along the beach one day,
and it just came to me
to use it as a canvas.
I just put my finger in the
sand and made a giant fish.
I became really, really obsessed with it.
I left behind the world, both of surfing,
and a job as a chef,
and then I just put everything
into drawing in the sand.
There was almost no one in the whole world
that did this kind of thing.
I've drawn in the sand around the world:
Australia, Uruguay,
Argentina, Chile, Russia,
and occasionally a
commission, but also in places
where, "Oh there's a nice patch of sand,
"I think I'll go do something there."
The one that was 10 miles in circumference
in the desert, on a dry lake,
it's a Guinness world record, largest art.
I've walked as much as
30 miles in one day,
which means about seven
or eight hours of walking.
I like the stick probably the best,
because I like to come down
to the beach with nothing.
The tools are sitting there on the beach,
sticks to choose from, and
I'll do my composition.
Do a nice big drawing and then
I'll throw the stick away.
Come down with nothing
and leave with nothing.
For me, that's the most
fulfilling choice of how to do it.
Drawing in the sand is the
ultimate of in the moment,
and I wanna finish when the tide is about
to destroy the drawing.
This is gonna change every day.
Anything I do down there is gonna be gone,
and every time I'm gonna
have a big, huge place
to try something new.
(upbeat electronic music)
(ringing)